but Carnegie Mellon made the computer
welcome to nil Simon Hall named after
the founders of artificial intelligence
let's meet a robo session as tank
fell there
hello tank
what can I do for you there's a rumor
going around that tank has a girlfriend
let's find out who she is tank do you
have a girlfriend now I had another date
time Zilla the scoreboard at Heinz Field
she was a bit large okay
she's massive but Who am I to judge
there are many other exciting things
there's a few feet away let's go take a
look
right now we're standing in front of the
human-computer interaction Institute
also located in this building or the
language Technology Institute and the
robotics Institute which is home to art
art and racing team hard racing just on
the urban challenge which featured boss
a self-driving SUV as it navigated
itself through city streets so I know
you've all heard of the US Open but have
you ever heard of the International
RoboCup Federation US Open well Carnegie
Mellon has entered into this competition
multiple times
featuring soccer-playing robotic dogs
and microscopic nanobots recently we've
even placed 1st and 3rd in this
competition